[Music]
hi
everyone my name is lee bondstra and i'm
a developer advocate for google cloud
and i'm focusing on conversational ai
i'm also the author of the a press book
the definitive guide to conversational
ai with dialect flow and google cloud
you can find me on twitter via ladysign
and today i'm going to present to you
the workshop on how you can integrate
dialogflow in your flutter applications
for this we of course will need flutter
and flutter is a development suite for
building
uis in the past it was uh you could use
this framework for
building mobile uis but lately you can
build
any type of application with flutter
whether it's also for desktop or for web
and people use uh choose flutter
because it you can very quickly develop
an application
and that runs cross-platform and you can
make use of all these nice ui
components now dial up flow
that is a development suite for building
conversational uis
so that has everything to do with
chatbots and voice bots
like speech to text text to speech and
that is powered of google cloud or
powered by google cloud
it makes use of machine learning uh for
example we do intent detection which is
kind of like intent classification
the way how it works is dialogflow that
runs in the cloud
it's uh you log in on the interface and
then
as a developer or designer i feed it
training phrases as
examples and dialogflow makes use of an
nlu
part natural language understanding so
your end users that are either typing to
your chat bots or they are speaking to
your chat bots
um it will map whatever they say or
or type to whatever the training phrases
that you used in dialogflow
and based on that it will return you a
response
now dialogflow comes with lots of
integrations
for example you can integrate it in in
twitter or facebook or or web but if you
want to build a mobile application yeah
you have to do this custom and that's
what we're going to do today
now with dialogflow you can create all
types of chat bots
obviously the the web chat bots where
with the textual interface
and these are the little pop-ups or
iframes on websites
but you can also build voice assistant
apps with dialogflow
such as for the google assistant or
callbots where you have chat bots
in telephony contact centers
and the last category these are the
custom voice ai bots
and maybe you have custom hardware or
iot devices and you want to integrate
your
your voice bot your voice ai on on top
of that
now that is exactly what we will do
today although we don't use custom
hardware we will use a mobile phone and
in our case android
but it will work this workshop will also
run on ios devices
just follow along the steps now maybe
you're wondering like well why would you
create your own voice ai
why shouldn't you use the google
assistant i actually get
often a lot of people asking me like hey
lee how can i integrate the google
assistant
in my app and let's say you're a bank
you want to integrate a voice ai
in your banking app and people always
ask me how can i integrate the google
assistant in my app
and then i always ask my customers back
like well is that really what you want
because they're i mean the google
assistant is a great ecosystem and it's
great but it's also
publicly available it runs across every
assistant powered device but and you can
invoke
those actions by saying the wake words
so hey g
and talk to my app and with that you get
the full ecosystem so
like instead of only asking questions
about my banking app i could also ask
the
recipes or the weather information and
that might be an overkill if the only
thing that you want to do is having a
voice ai
in your your custom mobile app so this
is exactly why
we're going to build our own voice ai
and we can do this with dialogflow
and flutter will use that for the
the mobile app interface now there are
typically two approaches
on how you can integrate dialog flow in
your mobile flutter app
the first approach which is the approach
that we will use today
that is by using an flutter package or a
dart package
and there are so constant pros uh
on both approaches for the the flutter
package approach
and that means it's very fast you just
include it in your pubspec and now
you start writing the code and it works
you don't need a backend you don't need
to pay for a server
it just works but there is an important
part that you need to uh
be very careful as soon as you're going
to build production applications you
need to be sure
like what or how do you secure your
application what do
you do with your service accounts now
when you are building applications in
google cloud
you always make use of an api key or
service account which is a json file and
the json file contains
the project id of your google cloud
project and also the api keys
and you give it access restrictions or
access rights
in order for the service account to make
use of all these google cloud
technologies
and now you could say of course like
well i only assign dialogflow to my
service account so there's not a big
deal if somebody gets access to the
to service account because let's face it
hackers could decompile your
mobile application and then take the
service account out of it
and you could think like well it's not a
big deal because i only give access to
dialogflow
um so nobody can mine bitcoins on it
yeah that's true
but the fact is with dialogflow we or
you could
enable logging in dialogflow and
therefore yeah you could
uh collect pii data all the chats that
are coming in yeah that's that's
access to your google cloud account if
somebody bad has that service account
key
um yeah then they can get access to that
data so that's maybe embarrassing for a
production app
if you do want to go with this approach
because it's definitely possible
uh but you probably want to do some
additional tasks on top of it either you
want to
do something with rotating tokens and
then i'm sure
there are floater packages available for
that or you maybe run
parts on the back end or maybe
everything on the back end
uh the nice thing is with since we're
using a package which is dart code you
could run it in cloud run if you want to
but you just need to be careful of this
like you for production apps just be
careful uh
what are you doing with your service
account we won't go that deeply today
but i am pointing it out
the other approach that you could use is
by building the whole dialogflow part on
your server side
and this is great for when you're
building multi-channel bots so let's say
that you're also creating a telephony
chatbot um twilio that also talks to
dialogflow
and then maybe you want to build the
backend only once you can also do this
of course with dart
and flitter code um or you write it in
some other language that's fine
yeah but that means of course that you
need to maintain a server and also pay
for it
and on top of that that's also not as
easy you
talk from the flutter to the back end
with hdp and web sockets
and then communicate code
for an http response could look somewhat
how like this but yeah and then a
multi-channel body it could look like an
architecture like this so maybe you have
a google assistant and you have a web
chat and a flutter application they all
talk to the same back end
it's a really nice architecture but
again that takes a lot of uh
yeah a lot of knowledge and when you're
working in an enterprise probably also
multiple teams
so this is exactly why we're going with
the approach of using a dialogflow
flutter package
i created my own package which we will
use for the workshop shop today
it's called dialogflow underscore grpc
and
uh yeah it will be a very easy way to
build chatbots and voice bots so speech
to textbots which means that i speak and
then it captures the text and
returns me an answer on the screen you
can do that with this
package so um before
we'll dive into the the steps i'm gonna
show you how it will look like
so here you can see this is the app on
my android device
and you will see that there is like this
little um microphone button that i can
press
and i could ask a question like who is
using dialogflow
and while i'm talking you see that it
starts capturing my voice
and when i press stop then it
shows the result on screen we'll shoot
it later also in the emulator
right so now i know that
at this workshop will have a lot of
steps
so it's probably best if you just watch
me going through all the code and
and explaining to you all the steps uh
before you're diving it in uh yourself
i mean you could do but i just want to
mention it's uh it's a long code lab
where we use
a lot of different technologies it's
probably
the best if you just have a look and see
how i am doing these things
the chatbot that we are will build
basically
scrapes faqs from a website and i'm
using my own website in this case where
i have some
q and a's on the product dialog flow and
the chatbot will load these faqs inside
of dialogflow and
flows then integrated in flutter so you
can ask these types of questions
and it will return you the answer
now feel free to ask questions if you
have any questions or if you have any
comments or feedback that you want to
share with me
i invited today a group of google
engineers that
are helping me with answering their
questions so if you are registered for
the workshop
i think there will be a q a feature in
the in this interface
press that button and uh start
interacting and
also me i will dive into the questions
afterwards uh at the end
yeah let's get started
so i'm expecting but i'm not of course
not sure
that you already have a flutter
environment up and running
you can have a flutter environment for
mac os or windows you can even run it on
linux and chrome
but what you will need is you will you
will basically download footer on your
java path
and probably you want to download
android studio and
flutter also comes with slaughterdoctor
so when you run flutterdoctor on the
command line then it will tell you
exactly if you
correctly installed all the all the
tools and all the
emulators and uh yeah if if that
feedback is all okay then you can
continue and uh what we will do then is
we will
start by creating a a dialogflow
agent and you can do this by by going to
the dialogflow console
so you type in the in the url
console.dialogflow.com
and if it's the very first time when you
log in you log in with the google
account
then you click on this drop down bar and
it's probably empty for you
as i'm a dialogflow developer advocate i
have
many projects here but you probably
won't have that many but you click
on create new agent and when you click
on create new agent you get this
interface
where you specify you give it a name
your chatbot
and you you select a time zone take the
one that's the closest to you
please do not switch to a mega agent
setting
because you're not building a mega agent
a mega agent is kind of an orchestrator
that can talk to
many chatbots but we're not doing that
today and i would also advise you to not
switch the the global drop down to
switch to a different region of
dialogflow because
uh since we're making use of the faq
feature we are uh loading
faqs uh through the knowledge base in
our app so
that only works on the on the global
region
so you create an uh an
agent that way i think after after that
those steps you will uh click on the
cogwheel
and when you click on the cogwheel you
uh
have to enable the the beta features
because that is the knowledge base that
will make use of that
alternatively you could go into the
speech tab and you could enable
uh the the speech quality settings uh
this this works best if you
are um on a paid dialogflow plan then
you can improve the speech model
uh for the workshop it's not necessary
you could leave it the way uh
as it is yeah now the next step that we
will do is we will uh
go to the google cloud console where we
will create
a service account so you go to your
console.cloud.google.com and you can
start
searching for dialogflow api you need to
be in the project
that dialogflow created so when you
create a dialogflow agent under the hood
it creates a dial
a google cloud project so you select
that google cloud project in in the top
and then
in the search bar you can search for
dialogflow api
when you search for dialogflow api you
should see a manage button you click on
manage and
on the left side there will be a menu
with credentials
you click on credentials and this is the
place where you
can start creating a service account
so you create a service account you give
it a name
you can give it the description and then
you click on create and then the most
important step of this service account
is you need to
assign it some roles and we want to give
it dialogflow access rights
so you search for the dialogflow api
admin
you give that then you click on don and
at that moment
it created a service account you don't
have the key yet
the key you will get when you click on
the service account name
and then you hit on the key step
and from here you can say add key
create a new key it comes with a pop-up
you choose the json key
and you click create and at that moment
you store the
json key on your hard drive and later in
flutter we will copy this over to our
project
right
now let's start with flitter
and we will start by creating an
boilerplate application which is uh
like the demo application that you get
when you start a fresh new flutter
project
you can do this in android studio when
you create a new flutter application
or you could uh write on the command
line
in your terminal flutter create space
and then the name of your flutter agent
so i called it flutter dialogflow agent
and what this does it
generates the whole folder structure for
me that's great
i prefer to use the command line
personally that is because i
tend to do a lot of things on the
command line but i also have the idea
that it's super fast
um so if you don't have a preference i
would say
maybe choose to come outline as well
then you you get your project all
generated
and you can open it in your favorite
editor i'm using visual studio but you
could also use
studio that comes out of the box with
that with flutter and
there is an important setting here what
we uh what we need to do and
we need to do these steps the next
couple of steps before we start running
our application and installing our
application
and um that is because the the flutter
application where we will make use of
is um making use of a microphone
uh component uh the component is called
soundstream
and that's uh that plugin
[Music]
only supports the sdk version 21.
so for that we need to open the build
cradle files
and there are multiple build cradle
files but you need the one in the app
folder
so you go into the app folder and then
you click build cradle and then you
scroll down
and here is where you change the minimum
sdk version i believe by default it's 16
and you need to change it to 21.
then there is another setting that we
need to do is we need to give
permissions to our app that it can
allow to talk over the internet and that
the microphone is allowed to record
so of course dialogflow is a cloud
solution so you always need to be online
uh therefore we need to give the
internet permission and we need the
recording uh permission for in order to
use the microphone
so what we will do is we will go into
the app
source main folder where you can find
the android
manifest and this is the place where you
paste
the user permissions you can copy it
from the code lab and paste it
right right underneath the opening tab
yeah and again please do this before you
start installing the app on your
emulator or in your physical device
uh because it might become difficult uh
otherwise now you can see i have my
emulator running
because yeah
i'm using an emulator here and i could
start typing to the chatbot i could say
hi and the chatbot talks back to me
i could also start recording my voice so
i could say
who is using dialogflow
and you see that it was recording my
voice maybe you're wondering what's that
console showing on the left well i'm
actually logging the audio stream that
is coming in
and as long as these are not zeros so
this is a list or an
array with with only eight bit integers
as long as this is not zeros then i know
that there is audio streaming in
so at that moment then i know that
dialogflow should work on this as well
so this will be the end solution but we
will eventually will build
speech-to-text to capture the audio uh
to respond to written text and then we
will match it to a response from the
outflow which in my case is the
knowledge base faq
before we get there we need to add some
dependencies in our application
and and like i mentioned i'm making use
of the soundstream
um plugin in flutter this is just an
open source plugin that i found there
are multiple
uh microphone plugins uh available
online
you need a plugin for this because this
is a hardware feature
and this one works on android and ios so
you can start using it
um you you go to your pops up
spec file and here you you specify the
dependencies that you're using so
this is the soundstream one that we're
using we will also make use of dielectro
gfpc that's the one that i created
to integrate it with with diode flow and
maybe you're wondering what is the x
rx dart doing well actually the sound
stream integration the examples making
use of it so that that's why it's
why it's here now we also need to
um link it to our service account the
one that we just downloaded on our hard
drive
this is the moment when you start
copying it in your project
yeah folder so what you could do is you
will create a new folder called
assets and in the assets folder you drop
the
json key that you downloaded i renamed
it to credentials.json and i paste it in
the assets folder
and then in my pubspec i
write down assets asset slash
credentials so basically what i'm doing
here is i make a reference
and now and if i go too fast don't worry
you'll see these
all these steps in in the code lab you
can you can do this later
um i think in android studio when you
press ctrl save
it starts downloading all these
dependencies under the hood
if you uh work from the command line you
probably want to write down on the
command line flutter pub get
and then it starts downloading all these
libraries in your project
and and you can start um playing around
with this
and again here's the big caution warning
like if this is a production app
you do want to pay extra attention on
the circuit
on the service account because yeah a
hacker could decompile your application
and then get access to it which is what
we don't want
now you can run the application either
on your physical
device or on your virtual device i
showed you both in the beginning i
showed you that it was running on
android
i also showed you how it looks in the
emulator
if you want to run it uh on a physical
device and actually if you don't have a
preference i probably would go with the
physical device one
um because that is then you're
completely sure that the audio works the
way how
how it should work while on the emulator
your microphone goes to your laptop
and and i have seen occasions where the
audio cut
distorted and when you have distorted
audio i mean if you would picture it as
a wave like like a green wave
you know like distorted audio then would
make like like very big and up and downs
and that means that also the dialects
load the natural language understanding
and
i mean the speech to text will probably
uh
have a hard time figuring out what what
what it means
so physical device probably
uh won't have those issues but it might
work
as you've seen on my uh my laptop it
worked also with my virtual device it
depends on which one you create
on the physical device so if you use
android the way how you can debug on
your android is you will
go to your android settings and then you
will tap on your
build number a couple of times and on
the latest android version you need to
tap it seven times
and then you get like a secret developer
menu or a developer option screen
and in this developer options screen
where you get access to
that is where you flip the the usb
switch and once you have the usb
debugging enabled
then you can just plug in your your usb
cable
and as soon as you write flutter run
or you place the press the play button
in your android studio it will recognize
your physical device
and it starts installing the apk on your
device that's amazing
if you want to make use of an emulator
the virtual devices that's fine too you
can go into
android studio and you can create one
you can pick whatever
operating uh system and uh or android
version you want
and and what type of device and you you
can set it all up
now when you do this for the very first
time
you uh need to go into your emulator
settings and make sure that you enable
uh all the the the switches
that allows you to uh yeah let the
microphone work
and if you have like very strange
problems where you have the idea like
well i don't
feel that audio is working i don't see
zeros in my locks but
it still doesn't work sometimes it might
be wise to record your audio
and play it back in a wav file and
through your flitter code because then
you can exactly see how dialogflow gets
the audio
now by now what we did is we created
like this example app
and doesn't do anything with dialogflow
yet but that's fine
it's um everything is set up in the way
that we can start using
uh start using the code write the code
which is what we'll do in the next step
we will create the the chat interface
and uh you could copy it from the code
lab or you can click on this link
because i put the code all in github for
you so that's easy that means you can
just do a ctrl
a ctrl c ctrl v and paste it in your
project you will create an
um a chapter dart file
so that's a new file and that's where
you put all the contents
in and this is the place where we will
eventually uh integrate our dialogflow
stuff into
we will also uh create uh or we already
have a main file
and the main file this is where we link
the check the dart
interface to you can also get that from
this link and start copy
pasting it and what this file does it
it links the chat interface you can see
that here
now what what this chat are doing it
basically draws out the whole interface
for me so in my case it's an orange
interface
where you see like space list view for
all the chat balloons
you will see like a little text area
with two buttons
one is the send button but it also work
on enter key
and you will see the microphone button
that you can press and hold to start
recording your audio
that's that's all for now yes that's all
for now
um i have to speed up um
time wise but um let's quickly go to the
the dialect flow settings
what you need to do and what i did here
is i created some
uh some to do's so i created
an um to do the first to do is for
loading the the library in your package
or in your in your chat dart file so you
load
the my custom code the grpc file
the next step what you will do is you
will create a dialogflow instance
then you will integrate the service
account
and the service account now we have the
reference so this will work
it links it to the service account and
once you have the service account you
can start to create a dialogflow
instance and it now knows the project
idea where you're into so
you or only your flutter app can talk to
your flutter agent
and uh yeah you can start running detect
intent calls on this and this is what
we're doing
in the in the
the handle submit method the handle
submit is once you type in
code in your emulator and you press
enter
then what it will do it will take your
written text show it on screen and
uh it will make the detect intent call
and what you can see this is a future
which means is asynchronous code
it loads the the text
and it start detecting and get the
answer from dialogflow and
store that in the fulfillment text and
from the fulfillment text we will print
this on the screen
now the second part that is the the
handle stream method this is the
place where we will create the voice bot
or in our case the speech to text
in in the speech to text what we will do
is we will
um first of all there is an audio stream
subscription
this is done for the the microphone part
and what we're doing is like as soon as
you press the microphone button it
starts listening for the audio stream
and it's logging it
but it also adds it to the subscription
and this this
this audio stream this is what we will
eventually send to dialogflow because
that is where it gets my voice
from the very important step here is
that you need to create a configuration
where you need to assign a sample rate
you need to tell dialogflow the sample
rate that is using and that needs to
match to the sample rate that the
microphone is using
so in our case the sound stream package
makes use of 16 pcmi
mono data so we need to set the sample
rate hat to
16 000 and we need to set the encoding
to audio encoding linear 16 this is very
important otherwise it won't work
i did an additional step here i am
creating a bias list
because my faqs are
making uh use of product names and so
and i
am i'm not sure if my
my speech model will understand these
words or that it will
misunderstood my wording so this is why
i'm giving certain
words a boost uh that way i influence
the speech model to make sure that it
always understands whatever
i i'm speaking out
now and then the last thing what you're
doing here is you do the
streaming detect intent where you pass
in the config
and you pass in the audio stream that we
get from the microphone
and we start listening in so in real
time dialogflow will start listening
in and return answers to me and if there
is
an answer matched so if the intent was
matched
then we are printing it on screen in a
chatbot message
and and
okay i have a few more minutes left and
that's great
if you build this now you can start
playing around with dialogflow
and um this is also the moment where i
would say that you after
you're done with writing the code you
should start testing it in your emulator
or physical device
uh the very first time when you start
your application
you will get a pop-up that asks you
um if you are having the permission uh
for uh for using the microphone and you
need to say yes
uh while using the app and once you do
that
again make sure that you really enable
the microphone in the emulator
here then it will work and then you can
start playing around with this
and and like i said if you have the idea
that you don't see
zeros if you don't see zeros then
there's likely something wrong
or if you see zeros then there's likely
something wrong with the
permissions if you don't see zeros if
you do see numbers but dialogflow is not
matching
the audio to whatever you're saying make
sure that you have the right sample rate
set
and if this matches the hardware of your
device
and if you're 100 sure that whatever you
set in the configuration is the right
setting
um maybe you want to record your voice
and and play that back uh to be sure
that that the audio that comes in
is the right one or test it on a
physical device because then
you're 100 sure and um
and then you're good to go you can
improve the model as i said before in
the speech tab in dialogflow uh but you
need to be on the on the paid
version and then you have a much better
speech model
but the free version works fine as well
especially if you provide a bias list
which where you're like steering the
model to make
sure that let's say if you would create
an application you would say
i'm going out to eat pizza versus i'm
going to ibiza
which one is the right one well it's the
one that you give it the boost
so that's what you're doing here as
you've seen
our app is making use of uh speech to
text where i
use the microphone to record my voice
and i show the answer back on the screen
in text
if you're also curious in like well how
would i play back that audio uh to the
users
instead of showing it on screen but uh
yeah
playing it as audio well the good thing
to know is that dialogflow can return
text to speech if you enable this switch
in your
dataflow interface and then it returns
an
um a base64 uh
string in your response you probably
need to do some
uh conversion uh to get it in flutter
but
if you have a look into the soundstream
plugin
you do see that they are they also have
a player
so as long as you have a stream and you
attach it to the player then you can
start play whatever is in the stream
so yeah you could you could build a
with text-to-speech as well
now for the last part of this um
yeah this this workshop is the modeling
the dialogflow agent and as i mentioned
in the beginning we were making use
of the the faq and where i'm loading faq
questions in my app the first steps what
i'm doing here is i am
modifying the default intents so by the
uh standard if you start a dialogflow
application you get two intents the
welcome intent and the fallback intent
the welcome intent that's with the
that shows you the welcome message and
fallback is everything that can be
matched
will go to global fallback you can start
creating more intent
with custom training phrases or what we
will do today
is we will create a knowledge base where
we link it and fetch faqs from a website
so you click on
create knowledge base you give it a name
and now here is the magic you click on
create the first one and from here
you you give it a document name
and you specify that the type i choose
faq
because i have questions and answers on
my uh screen
you can make it even more experimental
if you have like a whole article
on the website then you want to import
and let dialogflow figure out the
questions and answers so you could try
that as well that's with
the second option but we're choosing
faqs
and this is a website that is available
online
it's important that this website is
available to search engine bots
um because it uses similar screen
scraping techniques that search engines
are using
so you select text html as a mime type
and then you specify the url that i have
in my um in my setup instructions
but you feel free to use a different faq
if you want to
build a different type of bot i'm
loading the faqs from my website
into dialogflow and when you click on
save
it starts scraping uh that that file
and uh yeah it will get all the
questions and answers in my dialog flow
i can check this checkbox to make sure
that it works on
automatic reload so every time when i
make changes on my website then
a couple of times a day it will start
fetching it again so make sure that the
chatbot is up to date with whatever's on
the website
and if you feel like because the faqs
in dialogflow there is natural language
understanding model behind this so i
could mistype this question and it will
still
figure out what the answer is but if i
would ask this question on a total
different way
like instead of the question in our case
would be like when should i use dialect
or
flow essentials versus style cx let's
say if i would ask
which one is better cx or es that's a
different type of question right but i
do want to return this answer
what i would do in that case is i would
provide training phrases so you promote
it to an intent
you say convert to an intent it becomes
an intent
and now i can start um
yeah i'm feeding a training phrases
which one is better and then it will
also make a match on questions like
these
typically i would say give it like 10 to
15 training phrases then you're good to
go then you're training a very decent
model
now if we go back to the knowledge base
center and you see here a slider
there you can specify like which one
will win will the knowledge base have a
stronger preference than the default
intents or not we're going to stick it
to
the default so which is like a 50 50.
um you scroll down and this is an
important step you need to specify
knowledge answer is one so it needs to
to get the answer from
from the from the question so if you
look here
and like it's it got this block but you
need to specify like what is the answer
that will be returned to the chatbot
and you could even put text before it or
after it but
you specify knowledge base article one
to make sure that that that will be
returned on screen
yeah you hit save and that is the moment
now you can start testing your
application
and you should see a similar app like
mine and it should work
so congratulations
now if you thought like well this is
amazing i would like to
play around more with this or maybe
you're interested in like uh
lee how did you actually build that grpc
uh
plugin well i explained this on my
weblog so if you go to my web blog
i i'm explaining the steps on how you
can create your own grpc package and
because the grpc package is basically
auto generated code
um with the sdk specs that's written in
the docs
so i'm explaining you how you could do
that just in case you have other ideas
for google cloud
components that you want to run in
flutter
if you're totally into building create
integrations like this
definitely stay tuned follow me on
twitter or
keep uh looking into the comments uh
later
next week of this video because we will
introduce a dialogflow cx competition
where developers can build their own
integrations everybody gets a free
t-shirt
and you can win cool prizes so that
might be interesting
and the other two links that i'm sharing
here is i created a white paper on how
you use
uh analytics for chatbots and
if you're interested in reading my book
please look on the a press
website with that i want to thank you
so much for watching today and have a
lot of fun
during the rest of the conference thank
[Music]
you
you